in our series the 2020s we are exploring
the big topics that will dominate the
conversation in the next decade this
morning focus isn't health the 2010s
changed how and where we received
medical help we found many breakthroughs
like CRISPR gene editing which opened
the possibility of curing genetic
diseases the FDA also approved the HIV
pill Truvada which can reduce the risk
of infection by 99 percent and
scientists used 3d printing to create
tissue for an artificial heart that
beats just like a normal human heart dr.
Jon LaPook is here to show us what we
might expect in the next decade before
we get to these future possible
developments we want to talk about
representative John Lewis and his
diagnosis with stage 4 pancreatic cancer
what's his prognosis and treatment
office options you know of course it's
very tough when it stage form meaning
that the cancer has spread outside of
the pancreas so we're looking at a
combination of chemotherapy use there's
a cocktail that people are given
depending upon the genetic analysis of
it they can have certain types of immune
therapy or some other specialized
therapy but you know it's it's gonna be
tough for him but there's always hope
you know never take away hope this is
one of the tougher it's a tough one
because by the time you get diagnosed
often it's just it's already spread
beyond the pancreas you know the
pancreas is in a place up here and your
upper abdomen where it can grow a cancer
and you don't even know what it's not
pressing up against things might give
you symptoms well looking into the
future can you see into the future the
NIH has started a trial to look at
whether there can be a universal flu
vaccine this last blue vaccine only had
like 29% of right goodness what do you
think are the chances we will have that
universal vaccine I think it's gonna
happen I spoke to Tony Fauci at the NIH
who is in charge of this effort and the
problem is and the reason why it goes
from like 20 to 60 percent efficacy you
know from year to year is that the flu
virus itself changes it mutates and so
it's like trying to catch up with it and
you're a little bit behind right so what
the universal vaccine does is it directs
the vaccine against a part of the buyer
that doesn't change it doesn't change so
I'm very hopeful as is Tony pouchy that
we're going to get something really good
so dr. LaPook a lot of developments
obviously there's a lot of studies out
there that are finding that artificial
intelligence may actually assist in
finding an illness what does that mean
for for us in the next decade it's gonna
be huge you know with an asterisk we're
gonna have to use it you know with
wisdom so right now computers can read
x-rays well MRI even look at a mole and
say is that likely to be a melanoma oh
the thing is gonna be we're gonna have
to do studies to see you know what is
actually real what's actually helping us
and what isn't I spoke to dr. Paul
Friedman who's the head of cardiology at
the Mayo Clinic he had the coolest
device it is a stethoscope which
normally if I listen to your heart I'm
gonna listen to you murmurs maybe the
rate to see if there's an irregular
heartbeat it's also picking up an
electrocardiogram but that's not all
what it also does it's a check it makes
an electrocardiogram and based on
artificial intelligence it can help
predict whether or not that person is in
heart failure how does it do that or
whether they're at increased risk of
developing heart failure that's gonna be
a big thing and the FDA has given a
breakthrough status to try to see if we
can get on the market with that last
question I think there'll be an HIV
vaccine
okay so Tony thought you again at the
NIH and charge of this vaccine right now
the problem is the vaccine is not good
enough yeah it's like about 30 percent
effective but you said you don't have to
get up to 90 percentage you can get up
to 50 to 60% effective then combining
that with Truvada and with condom use
and other preventative measures you
could probably have saved millions of
lives thank you so much dr. with much to
look forward to
you